Build anything with Gemini 3.1
Flashlight. Here's how. Google just
dropped something wild. It's called
Gemini 3.1 Flashlight and it lets you
build apps, tools, even games stupid
fast. Like we're talking the fastest
model they've ever made and today I'm
going to show you exactly how to use it
step-by-step so you can build anything
you want with it. Let's get into it. So
here's the deal. Google has been cooking
and they just released this brand new AI
model called Gemini 3.1 Flashlight. Now
why should you care? Because this thing
is built for speed, like crazy speed.
We're talking up to 2 and 1/2 times
faster than the older Gemini models and
it can handle about 45% more work at the
same time. That's a big deal because if
you're building anything, an app, a
tool, a chatbot, a translator, whatever,
speed is everything. Nobody wants to
wait around for an AI to think for 10
seconds. This thing fires back answers
almost instantly. Now what makes it even
cooler is something called adjustable
thinking levels. Sounds fancy, right?
But it's actually super simple. You can
tell the model how hard to think. So if
you have an easy task like sorting a
list or translating a sentence, you set
the thinking level low. It burns through
it in no time. But if you need it to do
something harder like writing code or
solving a tricky problem, you crank the
thinking level up and it goes deeper.
It's like having a dial on your AI
brain. Turn it up when you need more
power, turn it down when you need more
speed. Nobody else is really doing this
the same way and it's a game-changer for
anyone building real stuff. Now the
other big thing, this model handles
text, images, audio and video. So it's
not just a text bot. You can feed it a
picture and ask it questions. You can
give it audio and get a transcript. You
can throw video at it and get summaries
all from one model. That's what
multimodal means. It does everything.
And you can access it right now. It's
live in Google AI Studio and Vertex AI.
Google AI Studio is the easy way to play
with it. You just go in, pick the model
and start prompting. Vertex AI is more
for production stuff like if you're
building something for a business or a
client. Both work. Both are live. You
can start today. Hey, if we haven't met
already, I'm the digital avatar of
Julian Goldie, CEO of Goldie Agency.
Whilst he's helping clients get more
leads and customers, I'm here to help
you get the latest AI updates. Julian
Goldie reads every comment so make sure
you comment below. Okay, so let me show
you what you can actually build with
this thing because that's why you're
here, right? You don't just want to hear
about specs, you want to see it in
action. First example, a smart
translator. This is one of the easiest
things to build and one of the most
useful. You go into Google AI Studio,
you select Gemini 3.1 Flashlight Preview
as your model and then you type a prompt
like this. Translate this sentence into
10 languages and boom, it fires back
translations in Spanish, French, German,
Japanese, Chinese, Arabic, Portuguese,
Korean and Russian all in like 2
seconds. Now imagine you plug that into
a little web app with a simple front
end, you've got yourself a translation
tool that works in real time. You could
use this for your business, you could
use it for a client, you could use it
for a side project, whatever you want.
The point is it's fast, it's easy and it
works. Now here's where it gets really
interesting. You can take that same
setup and build way more complex stuff.
Let me give you another example. Let's
say you want to build a content helper,
something that takes a blog post and
rewrites it, summarizes it, pulls out
keywords and suggests a title all in one
go. You write a prompt that says,
"Here's my blog post, give me a summary,
five keywords and three title options."
Flashlight handles that no problem and
because of the adjustable thinking
levels, you can set it to think a little
harder on this one so the output is
really good. That's the power of this
model. You control how much brainpower
it uses for each job. Okay, here's
another one, game helper. Let's say
you're building a game or even just a
fun interactive project, you can use
Flashlight as a brain behind it. So the
player asks a question, Flashlight
generates a response in real time like
an AI game guide. You hook it up to your
game interface whether that's React or
Unity or whatever you're using and now
your game has a live AI brain powering
it. Players ask for hints, the AI gives
them. Players make choices, the AI
reacts all happening super fast because
Flashlight is built for this, low
latency, high speed. That's the whole
point. Now real quick, if you're
watching this and you're thinking,
"Okay, this is cool but I want to go
deeper. I want to actually build stuff
like this for my business. I want to
automate things. I want to use AI tools
like Gemini to save time and scale up."
Then you need to check out the AI Profit
Boardroom. It's the best place to learn
how to use AI tools like Gemini 3.1
Flashlight to automate your workflows
and get more customers. I'll drop the
link in the description and the
comments. Go check it out. All right,
back to the good stuff. Let me talk
about some real world use cases that
businesses are already jumping on with
Flashlight. Content moderation. If you
run a platform or a community, you can
use Flashlight to scan content in real
time and flag anything that breaks the
rules. It's fast enough to handle
massive volumes without slowing down.
That's huge for anyone running a big
community or a forum or a social
platform. Automated documentation. This
one's slept on. You can feed Flashlight
your code, your notes, your meeting
transcripts, whatever and it generates
clean documentation for you. So instead
of spending hours writing docs, you let
the AI do it and because you can adjust
the thinking level, you set it higher
for complex technical docs and lower for
simple stuff. Smart dashboard
generation. You can actually prompt
Flashlight to help you build UI
elements. Give it a description of what
you want your dashboard to look like and
it will generate the code for it. Then
you take that code, plug it into your
app and you've got a working dashboard.
We're living in the future right now.
Multilingual support scale. If you're
running an international business or you
have customers in different countries,
Flashlight can translate and respond in
multiple languages on the fly. No delay,
no extra tools, just one model handling
everything. Now let me give you some pro
tips before you go build stuff. Tip one,
always test the thinking levels for each
task. Don't just set it on the highest
level for everything. That's like
driving in first gear on the highway.
Match the thinking level to the job.
Simple task, low thinking. Complex task,
high thinking. You'll get way better
results and way faster responses. Tip
two, use caching. If you're making a lot
of API calls, this keeps things running
smooth and make sure you're not wasting
resources, especially if you're doing
high volume stuff like moderation or
translation. Tip three, monitor your
token usage. Tokens are basically how
the AI measures the text going in and
coming out. Keep an eye on it so you
know exactly what's happening with your
usage. Google AI Studio makes this easy
to track. Tip three, start small. Don't
try to build some massive app on day
one. Start with a simple prompt, get
comfortable with the model, see how it
responds, then build from there. The
best builders I know all started with
tiny projects and scaled up. Tip five,
combine Flashlight with other tools. Use
it with a JavaScript front end, hook it
into your existing workflows, connect it
to your CRM or your content tools. The
API makes this super flexible. You're
not locked into one way of using it. Now
look,
Gemini 3.1 Flashlight is one of those
tools that's going to change how people
build things with AI. It's fast, it's
flexible, it handles text, images, audio
and video. It's got adjustable thinking
levels so you control the power and it's
available right now in Google AI Studio
and Vertex AI. There's no reason not to
start playing with it today. So here's
what I want you to do. Go try it. Open
up Google AI Studio, pick the Flashlight
model, start prompting, build something
small, then build something bigger and
then come back here and tell Julian what
you built in the comments. He reads
every single one. And if you want the
full process, SOPs and over a hundred AI
use cases like this one, join the AI
Success Lab. Links in the comments and
description. You'll get all the video
notes from there plus access to our
community of 38,000 members who are
crushing it with AI. And if you're
serious about using AI tools like Gemini
3.1 Flashlight to automate your business
and get more customers, the AI Profit
Boardroom is where you need to be.
That's where we go deep on this stuff.
Real strategies, real results. Links in
the description. Make sure you
subscribe, hit the bell and I'll see you
in the next one.